hey guys something a little bit
differently today I thought as was
requested a very long time ago I would
go through some physics book
recommendations now this video is in two
parts in the first part this video I'm
going to go through some popular science
books which you might like to read if
you're interested in science as a whole
or possibly if you're interested in
doing science university specifically
physics these are books which can
determine which bits of physics you
might find interesting and whether you'd
like to take your study further and in
the second half of this video I'll talk
about some textbooks which if you're on
a physics course you might find useful
to use or if you're thinking about
getting ahead before starting a physics
course so books which you might like to
check out so start us off on the popular
science books quantum by magic kima this
is a book about the historical
development of quantum mechanics and it
is possibly the best popular science
account I've ever wrote
starting with Planck Bohr and Newton at
the start of the 20th century and
working right the way through
historically it's a really really
interesting account not just of the
science but of the people who are
involved in the science personally I
find the story of how science is created
and how historically this quantum
revolution happened to be just as
interesting as the science and this book
has both bibliographical elements and
also scientific elements it explains the
science very well because it starts off
when the science was initially quite
wise they're quite simple
we you know on a scale of relative scale
it was quite simple and then working its
way through the complexity as the theory
developed it's fantastic it's very
accessible actually I'd recommend this
to anybody whose GCSE level or above I'm
including links by the way to the Amazon
pages for all of these books in the
description in case you want to go out
and buy them or support your local
library next an absolute classic 60 G
pieces by Richard Feynman my copy is
extremely worn I have read this several
times and I've taken it on quite a few
holidays with me Feynman was known as
the Great Communicator quite apart from
being one of the most brilliant
physicists of the 20th century and in a
book of six chapters which are based on
lectures he gave it's it's basically
extract and the fireman lectures on
physics and they cover basic physics
like atoms and you know the notion of
how the physical world is constructed
and goes through gravitation
conservation of energy and some quantum
mechanics in the last chapter it's
basically like dipping your toe into
different bits of physics it's very very
accessible I'm not the world
biggest fan of Fineman even I have to
concede that it's it's you know
phenomenally well done it's not a
textbook to learn from but it's a very
very good place to start and if you're
interested if you think you might be
interested in physics in university I
would recommend this book probably above
any other also there's a sequel six not
so easy pieces which is about special
and general relativity if you know
you're interested in physics then check
this out they would recommend this is
quite a bit harder than six easy pieces
as a title suggests it was recommended
reading as part of my general relativity
course Oxford it's it can be a bit tough
going but it's it's absolutely
fascinating stuff and again very well
explained next not so much a physics
books as a maths book
Alex this adventures in numberland by
Alex bellos this is a book which
completely changed my view on maths when
I was in school I I never really liked
math I viewed it very much as a toward
that you used to do other things like
physics but what this book did was it
shows the the side of maths that you
just don't learn in school it shows the
more cultural side of things again the
historical development of the subject
and then things like how mass controls
the global gambling industry how PI as a
number has evolved over time and you
know ideas about different kinds of
infinities fans of John Green should
definitely read this one but it's
definitely a book which I recommend to
anybody who scientifically minded you
know in particular if you thinking of
doing physics in university you need to
get used to the idea of using math as a
tool but also appreciating maths more
broadly and this but does that
fantastically well this is something
which I I would recommend to literally
everybody now I'm going along two books
together the first of which is in search
of Schrodinger's cat by John Griffin and
the second one is the elegant universe
by Brian Greene now the reason that not
these two books together is because they
are books which I've read a long time
ago these were two books which really
got me into physics and kind of helped
me decide that I wanted to do physics in
university now because of this I can't
really comment on how good they were
because I can't remember a lot of the
discourse I couldn't I can criticize it
for example but I know that they got me
interested they're two very
well-respected books in such
Schrodinger's cat
is about quantum theory and a journalist
so not a scientist perspective they're
journalists perspective on quantum
mechanics and trying to get to the
bottom of what people mean when they
talk about these Schrodinger's cat a
thought experiment whilst the other
commune of us is about string theory and
Brian Greene is one of the top
scientists in the field he's written
this book about string theory which
isn't just about string theory it also
talks about all the science that's
necessary to understand in order to get
to string theory which is one of the
pinnacles of non physics and you know
it's a very good account of a lot of
modern physics I should say with a
caveat this is a little bit dense like
it's the kind of book you have to read a
page once or twice and then move on
there's a version which is not quite so
dense and a little more accessible
called the fabric of the cosmos also by
Brian Greene but this is the book I
think really we should maybe decide I
wanted to do a physics degree so take
from that what you will
lastly for the popular science books
quite an unusual one which is the
strangest man my grandfather now this is
a scientific biography and it's the best
biography I've ever read the titular
strangest man is Paul Dirac who is one
of my scientific heroes and has been
called the great expressionist physicist
since Newton now some people will argue
with that but it's undoubted undoubtedly
he was one of the greatest physicists of
all time he also had a fascinating
private life though notably he never
really talked people coined the Dirac as
a unit which was one word per hour and
they'd use it to measure how many words
it was necessary to keep a conversation
with him going he also had a very tragic
relationship with his father which is
times frustrating to meet about a lot of
times very touching and sad his father
in his child in Derek's childhood really
set him up as who he was for better and
for worse and I'll leave you to read
more about that in the book but this is
a very very very good book site so it's
references it also explains his science
which is very very high-level but it
does so in an accessible way ok so
that's it I hope you found this video
useful if you have any book
recommendations of your own please feel
free to leave your suggestions in the
comments and if you have any suggestions
videos you'd like to see me do in the
future also leave them in the comments
lastly my friend Fran this is Oxford
University physics Society president has
just set up her own YouTube channel
doing videos about different kinds of
physics she's just uploaded her first
which is about Cherenkov radiation and
if you'd like to check that out I
recommend you click her face on the
screen wherever I've put it and maybe
subscribe to it thanks for watching and
I will see you again next time